the ancient Maya were certainly the most  advanced civilization in the Americas  growing up in Belize I quickly realized  that there were thousands of ancient  Maya cities across this country in  Belize Caracol and Guatemala Tikal and  Mexico calakmul these were the  equivalent of London of Paris of New  York so what happened why were these  cities abandoned with the Maya goal I  turned to Nietzsche look now there's  certainly a very special place to me I  was the first archeologist to visit that  cave there portals for the underworld  where more important gods resided and  we're also seeing human sacrifice things  must have been really difficult for the  Maya to be doing this the Maya certainly  contributed to their own demise  we look at the Egyptian civilization we  look at Roman civilization Maya as the  Inca they all rose flourished but they  all came down at what point in our  civilization are we  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]